The Ragnarok between gods and humans is fierce!
What is the anime RECORD OF RAGNAROK like?
I'll tell you about its world and characters.
Let's fight, one-on-one!
Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
I love humans!
RECORD OF RAGNAROK is so exciting!
I started reading the manga lately, and I'm so into it now.
The Ragnarok between gods and humans is fierce!
Putting the existence of mankind at stake,
the world's representatives of gods fight against humans
in 13 one-on-one matches.
Just listening to the background story is enough to make me excited!
This time, to tell you what the series RECORD OF RAGNAROK is like,
I'll give you an introduction to its world and characters.
Also, I'd like to talk about what I would do if I were to fight in a match.
Well then,
let's fight, one-on-one!
First, I'll tell you the abstract of RECORD OF RAGNAROK.
All the gods of the whole world gather once every 1,000 years
to attend a conference in heaven
and decide whether humans should exist or not.
Because of the foolish actions of humans,
all members agree to put an end to humanity.
But right before that,
one from a group of demigoddesses called Valkyries,
Brünnhilde, raises an objection.
"Just wiping humans out is too dull.
Why don't we test the humans?"
What she proposed was
a final battle between gods and humans,
commonly called Ragnarok.
From the gods of the whole world and all humans in history,
representatives are chosen
to fight against each other one-on-one.
In a total of 13 matches,
the side that wins seven times first would be the champion.
However, it is absolutely impossible for humans to defeat gods.
Since the gods mocked humans that way,
Brünnhilde provoked them again.
"What? Are you scared?"
What she said infuriated the gods,
so they act out of anger and agree to have the Ragnarok.
Thus, from the seven million years of human history,
Brünnhilde chooses the strongest 13 humans
to get them to fight in Ragnarok.
Can humans outdo the gods and stop the extinction of humanity in the end?
A tremendous, crazy, serious battle begins!
Like this,
the gods who try to wipe out humanity
fight against human representatives one-on-one in this battle anime.
Now, I'll briefly introduce the characters in the anime!
First, it's this character.
Brünnhilde,
the eldest of the 13 Valkyrie sisters.
She is a demigoddess,
and she has a deep relationship with humans.
So she wants to avoid the extinction of humanity
and proposes the god-versus-human Ragnarok.
She isn't afraid to make an objection to the gods,
and she is a wise and brave lady.
But she sometimes has a sharp tongue.
She is the very person who proposes the fight between gods and humans.
She is a very cool lady.
But she actually makes very funny faces…
Next, it's this character.
Göll,
the youngest of the 13 Valkyrie sisters.
She loves Brünnhilde and calls her Hilde-neesama,
but nobody knows what she truly thinks.
She is cute.
I want her to call me "N-ko-neesama" too.
Next, I'll introduce the characters who fight
in the first round of the one-on-one battle of gods versus humans.
I'll start from the side of humans.
Lü Bu,
the human fighter in the first round of Ragnarok.
He is the strongest Chinese martial artist,
and Brünnhilde also praises him
as the most violent and craziest warrior she'd ever met on the battlefield.
Lü Bu is the extremely strong man
even in the Records of the Three Kingdoms, right?
There's someone remarkable fighting in the first round already.
The representative of gods who fights against Lü Bu is him,
Thor,
the god fighter in the first round of Ragnarok.
In Norse mythology, he is the strongest war god,
and he is also called the Thunder Berserker.
He uses Mjölnir, a huge Divine Treasure that is bigger than him.
Humans can't win.
He is too strong!
Anyway, how are humans going to fight against the gods?
Some people might think that way,
but there is something behind this.
The Valkyries can unite their souls with souls of the human fighters,
and they can transform their bodies
into the most suitable Divine Treasure for the fighter.
This power is called Völundr.
It makes defeating the gods possible.
That's right.
By using Völundr,
humans can somehow fight with gods,
but there is a huge price to pay when they use it.
Please watch the anime to see what price they have to pay for it.
That's all for my brief introduction to the world of RECORD OF RAGNAROK.
If the above information makes you interested in the anime,
please do watch it on Netflix!
N-ko's One-on-one Match!
Now, I'm going to have one-on-one matches with the production company,
the characters,
and the all-star cast of voice actors.
That is what I'll do in this section.
Who wins will depend on what I feel.
If I think I win, I win.
If I think I lose, I lose.
Well then, let's begin now!
It's party time.
The first round,
a one-on-one match with the production company.
Where is the production company?
JUNI TAISEN: ZODIAC WAR, PROMARE…
They are all strong anime.
I can't win if the crew is as strong as this.
So for now, the first round…
I'll let them win…
Next, the second round.
The character designer, what other anime did he work on?
A legend!
What should I do? Maybe I can't win even once.
I'll pull myself together and enter the third round.
A one-on-one match with the all-star lineup of voice actors.
They're all too strong.
My ears and my eyes are crushed.
I'm already worn out, but next,
it's a one-on-one match with the opening song.
I admit defeat.
RECORD OF RAGNAROK has completely defeated me.
It's really strong.
How was my introduction to RECORD OF RAGNAROK?
If it informed you even just a little of the charm of RECORD OF RAGNAROK,
I'll be very happy.
RECORD OF RAGNAROK is streaming on Netflix,
so after you watch the anime,
leave a comment or use hashtags, and let's talk about it.
I'd like to know your favorite character and favorite one-on-one battle.
Let's meet again next time!
See you!